speaking of friends are are you and and
if I'm wrong are you friends with
Colleen Ballinger still yeah I uh what
do you say about I've known I've known
Colleen for since I was since I was 12.
so for those that don't know Colleen is
in the middle of a kind of a
tough It's a Colleen what was the name
of the character Miranda Miranda Sings
my daughter my other daughter went to
all the concerts and everything and
she's getting accused of things yes
which we don't have to talk about that
She's accused of but
I would imagine if you're friends with
her you kind of met her when you were
young I was yeah I was 12 when I met her
and um she's always been nothing but
kind to me and her family nothing but
kind to me
um I
I think it's really
it's the first time that I've talked
about this I just want to make sure I
say my exact piece that I want to say
the internet
can take a lie
and run so far with it so far
that
it's
to the point where you just
can't do anything about it and I've had
that happen to me
and I
I know Colleen very very very well and I
think the work that Colleen has done for
for the internet is incredible I think
her creativity is incredible Miranda
Sings is a character is a comedian and I
think that it's very hard to be a
character where people are also looking
at you as you're a real human behind
that character and I think being a
comedian is very hard because you were
able to do things years ago that
were okay and now that we've grown and
we've matured we've realized that
they're not okay you know what I mean um
but you as somebody who's been in the
public eye for a long time
do you think that
um it is appropriate to communicate
openly with everybody that reaches out
to you no I I don't think
that communicating
with
fans is
you got to be careful to not and that's
what I'm saying to not blur a friend fan
line it's very tough and here's here's
my question to you regardless of judging
whatever specifically is being said that
was happening
and I'm just saying this is a parent
again you said you started communicating
her with her when you were 12. yes is
that is it you wanna but you guys were
in the same industry so we were like you
guys were making videos and stuff
together so we actually met because on
Dance Moms you know Todrick Hall yes so
on Dance Moms Todrick Hall had a party
and invited The Dance Moms cast and
three of the girls four of the girls
went and they discluded myself and Nia
it was another girl on the show
and we all knew Todrick so we were fine
with that but then Colleen as Miranda
surprised the girls and me and Nia were
devastated because we were massive fans
and we we loved Colleen and we loved
Miranda and then when the episode came
out Colleen saw how upset me and Neil
were
and she reached out to Holly and was
like I would love to like make this up
to you guys she was like I was wondering
where Jojo and Neo were like I'm I had
no idea that this was the case like
please like whatever you guys want like
I just want to make the kids happy like
I just want Jojo to not be sad anymore
and so we ended up going to dinner
um with Colleen and it was me and my mom
and Nia and Holly and Colleen was
telling me that night about YouTube and
how her whole family did it and how it
was awesome and she Vlogs her life and
that night is when I went home and I
made my YouTube channel and decided that
that was gonna be my career essentially
and um that's a wonderful sweet
appropriate story yes how are how is it
for you now being her friend and reading
some of what we read do you think it's
all a lie do you think it's
like have you talked to her there have
been a lot of people on the internet who
have gotten
hit with this cancellation and a lot of
them I know some of them I don't know
and I look at it and I see
that
this is a sensitive subject somebody
who is affected by
any sort of any any anything anything
having to do with adults and and
I mean
for real grooming is it's a very
sensitive thing
you must have young really young people
reaching out to you now
I mean I do and I it's it's funny like I
realized when I when I hit 18 I was like
oh this is different now like because
right you know you're you're young and
you're dumb and I was like I need to be
very careful about this like I know like
her daughter's a nine yeah if she could
right now and she watches you and talk
to you like she would and she would love
to be your friend and love to be online
and I'm sure you want to reach out to
your fans and be like hey give that back
to them since they're such a big chance
of you the difference with Colleen and I
is we were once I became her friend and
she became my friend and she became
somebody that I looked up to she became
somebody that I idolized she became
somebody that I was like wow this person
is a hard worker she's a genius she's a
very strong YouTuber and I I idolize
that you know and so throughout I mean
throughout our friendship we've probably
filmed a hundred videos together and
it's she's she's cool you know and I I
think the problem is the internet
was able to capitalize off of
her her cancellation and they still are
and they still are continuing to and
it's it's not okay because a lot of it
is based off of lies and it's well it is
a scary it's a scary place when you put
yourself it was one thing you know I I
came to television which is
totally different and I'm I'm new to uh
the internet and I kind of found it
through the kids but it is a really
it's like a Minefield it is
[Music]